We could also solve this problem by setting up a proportion. We can compare the
number of dimes and quarters in the ratio to the number of dimes and quarters in
our hand. When we set two ratios equal, we get a proportion. The number of dimes
in our ratio was 2. For our ratio we had 2 to 3, or 2 3rd. And in our hand, we
had 10 dimes, and I didn't know the number of quarters, so I'm going to use a
variable, q. Once the proportion is set up, we can solve for unknown amounts
using cross-multiplication. This method comes from multiplying both sides of the
equation by the denominators. Notice 3 divided by 3 makes 1, so I'm left with 2
q on this side. And q divided by q makes one as well, so I'm left with 3 times
10 or 30 on this side. We could've gotten to this step a lot quicker, if we
would have just cross multiplied 3 times 10 is 30, and q times 2 is 2 q, we
would get this equation. We want to be careful when we cross multiply. We can
only do it when there's one entire fraction on the left and on the right. If
there's other sums or differences, you should try something else. And then to
find the number of quarters, we divide by 2. So, the number of quarters is 15.